rust can be a little bit confusing when
you first get started this is an open
world survival game with no real goal
other than staying alive and considering
that you start out with nothing more
than bandages a torch and a big old rock
it's pretty easy to feel lost literally
and figuratively here are a few tips to
help tip the odds of survival in your
favor the first thing you need to do is
build yourself a hatchet you do this by
collecting pieces of wood and a few
stones what is the easy part
find any old tree and smash it with your
router
your inventory will automatically fill
up with the wood stones are a little bit
trickier you'd think that you could just
bash those rocky cliffs all around the
map but nope you need to find these
respawning boulders out in the middle of
fields smash away at a few of these with
old rocky and you should have enough
stones to get the job done now open your
crafting screen select stone hatchet and
assemble away congratulations and you
just made surviving slightly easier the
hatchet is useful because not only does
it make harvesting wood that much faster
it's also a much more reliable weapon
than the rock you start out with this is
important for your next objective and
rust which is to gather some food before
you starve to death your best bet is to
find a wild animal like a boar sneak up
to it and hatch it away now this next
part is important that raw meat you just
dropped through killing animals for the
love of God make sure to cook it on a
campfire eat it raw and you're in for a
world of hurt
virtual Salmonella is no one's friend
trust me on that one I've made that
mistake before now that you've got food
in a weapon you should focus on creating
shelter a simple Shack will do the trick
and building a wooden door to go with it
will keep you safe from animals zombies
and any player who doesn't have the
patience to hack away with it with a
hatchet just make sure to place your
shelter in a relatively low traffic area
like up in the hills or near the water
at the edge of the map anyone with
enough time and resources can break into
your shelter but tucking it away
somewhere quiet will help reduce the
chances of burglar
now find some cloth from dead animal and
build yourself a sleeping bag so that
you'll have a respawn point the next
time you die or log back into the server
oh and if you're in a sleeper server
that means that your body falls limp to
the ground when you log off so make sure
you log off inside of your shelter if
you don't want to get murdered in your
sleep with shelter taken care of you
should work on crafting yourself some
more advanced weapons something like the
bow and arrow a bow requires wood and
cloth while arrows require wood and
stone the bow and arrow is nice for
general defence against hostile players
but it's especially nice for hunting
zombies the undead do a lot of damage at
close range so taking them out from afar
is critical hunting zombies is a good
use of time because they tend to drop
really high-value items that you can't
craft on your own or at least not as a
beginner and finally a little advice for
getting around there's no in-game map so
if you want to know where you are you're
gonna need to cheat a little bit so
here's what you do hit shift tab to pull
open the steam overlay open up the web
browser and go to rust map dotnet you
can also just alt tab this if you want
now this map is a great way to
familiarize yourself with the games
primary landmarks so that you can have
an easier time getting around you'll
probably still get lost but at least
you'll be doing it less often than
before and with that you should be set
all that's left is learning how to deal
with other players hold via to use voice
chat so that you could tell them you're
friendly and hopefully they don't kill
you on sight just be careful around
players with fancy armor and those who
are building giant houses they're the
ones with the most to lose and as a
result they tend to be the most
offensive so just be friendly and you
should hopefully be fine excuse me sir
good luck and have fun out there for
more rust coverage make sure to go to
GameSpot calm
the trick